So,
uh,
I see this as largely what I'm cars,
not exclusively a female class.
And I know that's because of the reputation classes being very tough on on men.
And what have we learned about men so far?
They're violent,
they contribute only a speck of protoplasm to the next generation.
They help hardly at all.
And child rearing in the Tuesday reading you vent that they're even afraid of
their wives.
And on Thursday,
uh,
how many of you did the reading about the na wonderful self.
So what do they believe about man's role in reproduction?
Just to gardening.
They just water it that the baby comes totally from the woman's a substance and
men just have to water it.
Occasionally,
as you know,
water is water is water.
So it doesn't matter which man waters it and they have a very promiscuous
sexuality.
So feeling very sorry for the males.
Um,
and I don't want them to go through too much of an ego crush.
I have to tell you that some cultures indeed give credit to males in all of
this.
And in piggy of the Bari tribe of Venezuela who were one of the isolated tribes
in the,
in the am and the Venezuelan,
Amazon.
And they believe that a woman's body is just a vessel and that men do all the
work of,
of reproduction.
They only,
they only limitation maybe that the very first act of sex,
uh,
must be between husband and wife.
They have,
they have marriages.
But the first copulation has to be between husband and wife because that plants
the seed.
And it's very important that the seed belong to the husband.
But once he's planted this seed,
uh,
the growing fetus is not done with male need.
So the from the fetus obviously has to be nourished.
It's keeping to grow,
has to get the nourishment,
doesn't get the nourishment from the mother,
gets it from seaman.
So the fetus needs a constant war,
uh,
contribution,
of semen all on too to make it grow.
The Bari claim that this is very hard work for men to support a pregnancy and
you know,
they have to have sex just all the time to do this.
And the poor.
The women are worried about wearing out their poor husband's.
So,
and now this is not just this cultural,
you know,
just dreaming stuff up.
This has real empirical basis in the Bari.
Say,
look,
it's obvious.
Women grow factoring and pregnancy,
well men,
they grow thin from all their work.
So they have good reasons for believing what they do.
So what's the solution?
Well they ask other men to help.
The husband isn't,
they don't want to wear out their,
their husband and he's,
he's got to do a lot of stuff to ask other men to help and strange,
even though it is such hard work than me,
the men seem quite willing to pitch in and help.
And so it's so it's very nice.
It's very heartwarming that men can at least temporarily stop all this man male
competition and help another guy,
uh,
when he,
when his wife needs a little nourishment.
So
she likes that one.
When we get to discussing the reproductive biology that relates to abortion much
later in the course,
you will find that actually western scientific knowledge does not go much beyond
what the Bari understood until about 1840 and well into the 19th century.
And that's until then what,
how a fetus was formed,
what the male contribution was,
what the female contribution was,
was a big hot argument.
Some thought it was all a woman,
some thought it was all male and they just had no idea.
Human fertilization was not discovered until 1840 in,
in the,
in the West.
So,
uh,
we were having the same argument that the Bowery do.
Furthermore,
I,
anybody know approximately how long it takes if,
if a human couple wants to get for gets get pregnant,
how long it takes on average three,
it's more like five months.
And you'll hear that again when we discussed abortion,
you'll,
you'll hear the reasons for that.
So actually in that findings or the,
the,
the husband gets the first a copulation,
but thereafter,
uh,
a lot of guys have to help.
So by the time five months rolls around,
the average for getting impregnated,
an awful lot of guys have had their seed in there.
And so again,
in actuality,
paternity is totally uncertain that it comes right back to the,
to the chimp story that the community hangs together.
One reason because no one knows anything about paternity.
Okay.
So last time,
um,
I was describing how all cultures have mechanisms so that families in fact only
have about half as many children as we,
of which they're biologically capable.
Remember,
we did this calculation and we've found this 69 number and so forth.
And uh,
I was in the middle of his story and actually it's in your reading.
Uh,
reading for the last two is about the May my anger of New Guinea.
And they believe the males and females both believe that the sexual fluids and
odors and emanations from women are dangerous and even lethal to men.
Hence the men are terrified of having sex with the women.
Now,
you'll read this in your reading and uh,
you may again throw it off as just a one of these cultural practices of
primitive people.
That's not the way you should approach this class.
You should,
on the other hand,
ask,
how does such a practice arise?
What are,
what are its roots and how does it help their culture to survive?
The theory being that most of the things that people's do have some role in,
in helping them in a difficult world.
So as you know,
uh,
in,
in chimps,
as in most human societies,
they're x arguments that instead of the mail going out to meeting,
the males stay together in one community and the females go out for mating.
And the same is true with my anger and females transfer groups.
Also,
we know that as in chimps in New Guinea,
each of these tribes is always a constant warfare,
uh,
with their neighbors.
They are truly,
uh,
enemies.
Um,
so
when women are exchanged between neighboring communities,
they don't travel very far.
They'll get killed if they traveled very far.
So they only people they know,
or the neighboring communities and someone from this community will marry.
We'll get a woman from a fairly neighboring community,
which means getting an,
uh,
a wife from their enemy.
And that's again,
very similar to the,
to the chimp setup and the Manga are very much aware of this as you've read.
We marry the people we fight and there was a lot of distrust and fear of the
enemy lives because of that.
The husband does not sleep in the hut with his wife and children,
but sleeps in the men's hut,
the man,
and it's a male bonding sort of thing rather than a male female bonding sort of
thing.
And apparently culture has used this distrust of the wife,
this fear of the wife,
uh,
as a mechanism for restricting sexual activity.
Uh,
so of course my ankle,
like every other human has tremendously strong sexual drives,
but they living on very fragile ecological land and they can't,
uh,
overpopulated.
So they have to have some mechanism of camping,
uh,
down,
reproduction.
And so this is one of the mechanisms.
The men don't even sleep in the same house who am,
and it's a,
it's a rare event than the women when they visit the women are rare and
dangerous event.
And that keeps the birth rate down now.
And the reading.
There's a third point that that's very easy to miss because it's just one little
phrase when it talks about how dangerous is,
do you remember who it says is particularly vulnerable?
The young males are particular,
she remembers that the young males are particularly vulnerable to to these
dangers.
And so they're held to be undermined,
not only by frequent intercourse with with women,
but even by frequent contact with women.
But of course the older men are rather immune.
As you grow older,
you gather immunity to this.
Now we know younger males are driven very much sexually older males.
It cools down somewhat.
And so here's this cultural belief counteracting biology.
It's the inverse of what you would expect.
You'd expect the younger men to have a lot of sex in the older men to sort of
tail off on it.
But what does it ensure and ensures to control by the older dominant sex mature
men?
Again,
it goes right back.
It's the Manga.
It's,
it can be perceived as the May anger version of dominance hierarchy in the
chimpanzees.
Well,
uh,
there's an extended description of this in the reading,
which is wonderful,
which I hope you've already done.
So the,
the,
uh,
so so far we've been,
I've been describing how can,
how culture communities push fertility up because if you don't get like on
average eight or so children from each woman,
the culture disappears.
But they also have to push it down because of reproduction goes to wild.
The children just die.
I showed you data about introvert.
The interval can't get too short or the children just die.
But individuals,
that's all from the community perspective so far.
But individuals and individual families,
they have to adjust these rules.
There's these cultural rules which are usually very strongly enforced.
Uh,
but individual families have,
each has a different situation and they have to adjust the rules somehow to cope
with their individual situation.
And of course this leads to conflict between what an individual or an individual
family wants and what the culture says you must do.
And so one of these examples I mentioned last time is postpartum abstinence.
That in many parts,
for instance of Africa,
after a child is born,
there'll be three years in which women is not supposed to engage in sex.
Obviously primarily a mechanisms are spacing births so that the children stay
alive and the woman doesn't get killed from too much strain on her resources.
Now.
But if you think about that a little bit,
you have young woman,
young husband.
Marriage is fairly young.
Generally husband will be good,
bit older,
but still young and he's facing he's hazard.
The wife has a kid,
he has a kid and the wife is the husband now facing three years without any sex.
Why does he gonna do,
he's gonna want to take a second wife or maybe visit a lot of prostitutes a lot
and spend money.
Uh,
that's something that often the,
the wife,
the first wife or second or third or wherever she is in the chain will not want.
So sometimes she does want that.
And we'll talk about polygamy later.
And,
and why women very often choose to be in polygamous relationships,
but very often she won't want him to take another wife.
Authon unless he's got a lot of money,
he just won't be able to help more than one wife.
So what does she do?
She has to figure out a way of resuming sexual intercourse but not get pregnant.
What does she use?
Contraception.
So surprisingly in Africa,
one of the major reasons for the people accepting contraception is not a desire
to reduce fertility as an almost all the rest of the world,
but as arch resume sexual relationships without getting pregnant.
And she has to do this,
uh,
not only to protect herself because she knows that if she has children too
often,
uh,
she wears out her body and there's a reading on exactly what certain groups in
Africa,
one group in Africa considers this wearing out of the body.
But also if she gets pregnant right away,
the community knows that she and her husband had violated the taboo.
And there's very strong social,
uh,
prescriptions against proscriptions against violating the taboos.
So contraception,
which you take privately,
uh,
is,
is sort of the perfect solution for women wanting to return to sexuality but not
to get pregnant.
So,
uh,
another aspect which we've already just,
I just mentioned of control of fertility is what I call gerontocracy rule by the
rule by old folk.
And uh,
the old folk can monopolize,
the older men can monopolize,
uh,
the sexual activities of younger women and because they're not as vigorous,
shall we say,
that reduces is one mechanism for reducing fertility.
One of the ways which came up in one of the sections said you have bride price.
You know,
dowery is more commonly known is where the wife's family pays the husband,
the husband or the husband's family.
When the wife gets married,
the reverse of that is called bride price.
And it's much more common than dowery in Africa,
right?
Price in this case,
the man of the man's family or the mantra must pay the father of the wife for
the before he gets the woman.
It's sometimes in the West consider buying the woman,
but it really is not a buying situation.
And
these bride prices can be very high.
And a young man usually does not have the money to buy a bride who controls the
money of the village,
who controls the resources of the older men who are the village elders and
control everything.
So,
uh,
they dole out very sparingly,
the bride price to allow men to get married.
And this is like among the Messiah of Kenya,
very tall people,
which a lot of popular press about them.
And uh,
because the young men are not getting married and there's Russell equal numbers
of males and females that leads a lot of excess young girls,
fertile young girls and who gets them.
The older men go polygamous and they can have several wives.
But remember for every man was more than one wife,
that means there's another man that has no life whatsoever.
And
when you,
when you read the ethnography of this,
the anthropologist who go in,
it's very clear that the young men are held in a state of sexual frustration.
And the young men have ways that they talk to each other and they are just on
the verge of rebellion.
And the strategy of the older guys is to keep these young men just below that to
keep things as much sex for themselves,
but keep the young men from getting together and rebelling.
And so they coopt what we now we're would they call up the young guys when the
older,
more dominant of the younger guys,
when things get started to get out of hand a little bit.
Oh,
we now have bride price and you can go and get married and that co-ops him and
takes him out of the cabal that might start a small revolution.
So this,
this is all going on,
sadly,
often hidden within these communities.
Uh,
and it's,
these are large effects.
This whole polygamous situation in much of west Africa,
almost half,
half of all wives are in polygamous marriages.
And that means about half of the men have no wives whatsoever.
And in the 1920s so a lot of what I'm describing is traditional culture.
And you all know that the whole everywhere in the world is changing very
rapidly,
but you can't understand where they're going unless you know where they're
coming from.
So in the 1920s,
40% of the men got to be 40 years old without having been able to marry.
So that's half,
almost half of your population without lid,
quote,
legitimate sexual outlet until they're 40 years old.
And today,
even today,
and this is from a few years ago,
uh,
the meeting age of marriage is still almost 30 and great pressure and power from
the older guys is necessary to maintain a situation like that.
Uh,
they also leave a sort of a pressure valve on,
on this whole situation that they don't totally suppress the sexual activity of
young man.
Uh,
they turned a blind eye to a fair amount of prostitution,
and that's reasonably accepted.
And to miss a quote,
discrete to the younger wives have older brothers or even of their fathers.
So,
so again,
the,
there's the dominant males are sort of officially in charge,
but a lot of extra stuff going on.
Again,
it's,
it's the,
the great ape kind of pattern.
And even in today,
this story of the dominant older males getting the most sex has by no means
disappeared.
Now it gets a little,
uh,
more unpleasant because,
this control of population by pre modern chemical contraceptive societies,
uh,
is very often post-pregnancy.
We've described so far,
all kinds of pre pregnancy mechanisms,
reducing sex,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
But women still get pregnant and very often they are,
their families decide that they can't have this children.
So a lot of this is post-pregnancy,
uh,
population control and even and postnatal also,
um,
abortion and infanticide are common among,
on or have been recently among almost all human groups.
And so different communities and different individual families have different
amount of resources and they must match in some way match their fertility to the
resources that are available.
So this is a very discussed and studied topic,
uh,
in population circles.
So a few years back,
Karen Mason,
who was president of the Population Association of America and gave a wonderful
quote about how people adjust their family size.
Parents kill their infants,
abandoned them,
neglect them in the hopes that they will die,
give them into the care of wet nurses where they usually die,
sell them,
give them up for adoption,
marry them off at a young age,
loaned them to other families for fostering,
send them into service or into other households,
send them to the military,
the merchant marine prostitution,
or send them overseas as migrants.
All of these are very standard mechanisms for individual families controlling
the number of children that they have to rear.
And in Western culture,
it's certainly not unknown.
Uh,
the founding myth of the Jewish people,
Moses,
what happened to Moses?
He's a baby.
He's thrown in the basket,
floated down the Nile.
You go to China,
very standard way of getting rich on everywhere,
every culture that has a river,
uh,
babies or putting baskets and floated down the river as a way of getting rid of
them.
And of course the Bible story is that the Pharaoh's daughter finds this baby
floating down the river and uh,
you can believe that or not.
But obviously that sort of behavior of putting a newborn infant in a basket and
floating down the river was apparently extremely common at that time.
So the,
the story wouldn't have been surprising.
Yes,
that's the story.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
If you read the rich that you're,
you're completely correct.
If you read the original story,
it reads as if one,
she wants to keep him alive and Pharaoh was going to kill them all.
And two,
that she saw the princess sort of on the other side of the river and,
and thought that the princess w would see it.
So you can interpret the story as you want,
but it's a very standard multicom.
Many,
many cultures cross cultural mechanism and infanticide.
And there it appears.
What is the founding myth of the Roman people?
I'm going to stream.
It's what's the story of Romulus and Remus
raised by wolves.
So Ron Midstream is twins.
You're talking about twins a moment left out on a hillside,
right.
Standard form everywhere in the world of abandonment.
You know,
some animal eat it,
but in this case the wolves didn't eat the babies,
they suckle them and they came up to found the Roman empire.
Sure.
Uh,
so it's quite interesting how many of the founding myths,
uh,
have,
this abandonment,
a story in them respect to twins.
For instance,
the [inaudible] tribe who are very traditional isolate people in Columbia,
in South America,
uh,
when they have twins,
they abandoned them and the forester or tossed them into the rivers and their
cultural belief is that they bring bad,
bad luck.
But of course,
you know,
in,
in the situation where mothers under nourished,
she probably is going to have difficulty bringing up one child.
And two is just kind of impossible.
If she believes where the culture has sort of over history figured out that the
children are going to die one or both of them,
then the amount of resources put into trying to raise a child who you know is
going to die anyway is just not,
not acceptable.
And of course,
none of this is,
is a conscious calculation.
Uh,
if you asked the people why they're doing it,
they always give some kind of religious or mystical or magical kind of
interpretation to this behavior.
But we can see it as one of these mechanisms for having families limit their
fertility to what they think they can cope with.
Um,
so in addition to controlling the rate of reproduction,
the control of population continues after birth.
Uh,
and we haven't talked about abortion,
but during pregnancy,
Avaya abortion,
we'll get to that later.
Societies are also really very,
uh,
careful about controlling the number of child bearers and the,
in England for instance,
and we'll talk a little more about this at a later time,
people couldn't marry the,
the,
the peasants on somebody's estate could not get permission to marry unless he
had enough property to support a wife and children.
And very often this meant that he couldn't marry until his father died,
that the father was living in the house and he just had to wait until the father
dies.
And then he was owner of this property,
then he could take a wife.
Well,
the father dies is when the guys may be 40 or late thirties.
And so that cuts down his reproductive potential a lot.
And of course,
the wife that he marries,
uh,
has,
has not been married up up until then.
So her reproductive potential has also been knocked down.
And,
uh,
in many ways,
since the fertility of a society basically does not depend on the number of men,
depends primarily on the number of women.
Uh,
we saw this last time,
we discussed the permissability of,
of polygamy,
even with limitations when a lot of men are dying in war.
Um,
but,
uh,
this happens in many,
many situations in India as,
as you know,
traditionally it's almost never practice.
Nowadays a man dies.
What happens to the wife
sacrificed on the funeral pyre?
Again,
there's all kinds of religious and cultural explanations for which the people
who tell you,
but standing back from it,
among other things,
it's a way of controlling,
uh,
the birth rate of the population.
Sometimes in a single,
uh,
geographical setting.
You can see the,
the,
the two different things,
uh,
working together.
So the Ma,
the my anger,
which you've already heard about in New Guinea,
they live in an overpopulated territory.
They are pressing up against the ecological limits of their resources.
So the women are severely degraded.
Uh,
funerals are held to honor man,
men and pigs,
but not women or children.
If a,
if a husband dies,
if a man dies,
his widow is strangled within 24 hours of his death on the same island.
In New Guinea,
the foray,
people have a different problem.
They have Kourou,
you know,
which we now called Crites felt Yacob disease,
a prion that destroys the brain.
So they have a very high death rate and their territory is,
is quite underpopulated.
They have great difficulty in getting enough people to stay alive.
So in that culture where everybody is scarce,
uh,
they mourn women and children as much as men.
They encourage premarital sex and widows are not killed but courted for
remarriage by the men.
Again,
this is a Saturday when you're way below the limit,
then you want to keep a woman's womb fall and you want to keep them reproducing.
And so I've told you this mechanism for reducing the number of child bearers is
severe,
very severe around the world.
Now.
And I mentioned,
and we'll hear it again,
that the estimates are that there by various mechanisms of discrimination
against women,
there's 100 million women missing in the world.
And this is a big part of the global,
uh,
control of population.
So we've seen,
you know,
some people and a lot of the popular discussion thinks that,
uh,
fertility control,
contraception,
all that is a new thing that's burst in 1960 or something when the pill was
invented that is burst on the world.
And some people think it's wonderful and some people think it's immoral,
but in fact,
coaches have always have,
uh,
have had mechanisms for controlling their fertility and they've often been more
brutal than,
than what we current,
uh,
the have [inaudible].
So I want to shift gears a little bit.
Um,
it falls on the following way.
So we've been talking about the way people regulate their fertility.
And what is the main limitation on fertility?
Well,
it's often food and food depends on how much land you have.
So most of what we read in history and what we're used to thinking of human
society,
uh,
has to do with very crowded places from Europe or China or India in historical
times.
All of these places have had very high,
you know,
historically compared very high,
even dense populations.
And in all of these cultures,
you have masses of,
of peasants without any land,
landless,
landless peasants,
they called Land Hunger.
Everybody wants land and there isn't land for it.
They fight over land.
If you manage to own land,
you're going to be very rich from the land.
You don't have to work at yourself.
There's always plenty of landless peasants that can do the work for you and so
forth.
So this is pretty much true of,
of,
uh,
pretty much the characters of recent human history.
But for most of human history,
that that was not true at all.
The opposite was true.
The world was,
was open,
and there was plenty of land available.
Uh,
we were not a numerous species.
We had almost no population growth rate.
And so what was scarce was not land.
Land was plentiful,
but what was scarce was people to fill up the land and cultures have been aware
of this problem as well as the opposite pump.
But this problem for a long time.
So,
uh,
one of the great Chinese philosophers,
a merger a fifth century BC wrote what is hard to increase?
He's talking about politics and everything.
Only people are hard to increase.
And he argues,
he says that there are policies which can increase population.
The kings of old required that all men married by the age of 19 and all women
married by the age of 14 now those who want to marry early Marriott 20 those who
want to marry late Mary,
his latest 40 we can expect two or three more children to survive.
If we were reduced to reduce the age of marriage through universal marriage,
we should be able to increase the population size.
This is his advice to the rulers on how to increase the population in their
territory.
There's plenty of land that's not a problem.
They have to be strong because there's neighboring warring states.
They're always fighting with each other.
If they're not,
don't have a big population,
their neighbors who will come in and wipe them out.
And of course,
this idea that the government should be an agent of control of population,
uh,
again has not disappeared.
China does it now.
In the old days,
they wanted to use the government and did sometimes who's government to increase
population.
China now wants to use it to decrease population,
but it's the same idea that control in one way or another is important for every
society.
So in this,
the rest of this lecture,
and we'll see how long it takes,
uh,
we're going to talk about under population of,
of places.
And the examples are largely going to come from the tropics.
And especially we're going to talk about Africa.
And that is because until recently,
the tropics have generally had not had a dense population.
They have been what you might call underpopulated.
People were scarce.
And up to now we've been talking about,
we've talked about biological determinants of,
of population,
size of reproduction,
we've talked about cultural determinants.
There's another whole big factor,
geographical determinants.
And we're going to talk about three very important geographical determinants of,
uh,
of population size.
And largely we're using the tropics as an example of this.
So the tropics generally have low agricultural productivity.
The great grand juries of the world are not in the tropics.
They have parasitic diseases which are endemic and geographically they're often
isolated from the rest of cultural worlds.
So,
uh,
let me,
so this is the,
uh,
just a general map of Africa and what you see is this is a very standard,
here's the,
here's the equator and I'm sorry here is
that this is the equator up here.
So what you have is in a sub Saharan Africa,
well,
in all of Africa you having the center,
a rain forest.
This is the very traditional jungle and it's flanked north by the Sahara desert
south,
uh,
by the Kalahari desert.
Uh,
then here you'll see him or is another Green Zone right along the ocean and the
very north,
this is Tunisia and Algeria.
Morocco,
I'm sorry.
Yeah,
just the coastal sections of Africa are green again.
They have rain.
So we're not going to talk about North Africa because that's included in the
Mediterranean world,
just culturally,
not Sahara desert device.
We're going to talk about sub Saharan Africa.
You may note that these deserts continue into Saudi Arabia,
then into the sin desert of Pakistan and the Roger Stone desert of India.
And then the Himalayas interrupted,
but you get the Gobi desert up here and it continues across.
And in the Americas,
uh,
there's the,
the Amazon around,
uh,
around the equator.
Very dense jungle.
And what's the desert to the north of Amazon,
the Sonora desert of Mexico,
New Mexico,
Arizona.
That desert is in the same,
similar geographical position to this.
It moves up and down.
And what's the southern desert in South America?
Okay.
The Atacama desert of Chile,
Chile.
And you go over the Andes and it's not quite as desert,
but it's the,
the pump us,
which is a very dry,
dry,
dry region in Argentina.
So all over the world you have this,
a central zone around the equator,
which is extremely wet,
flanked by a desert zones.
And then once out of the desert zones,
uh,
you got a moderate rainfall again,
quickly.
The reason for this is quite simple.
Uh,
this is the tropics.
heat comes down,
the hot air rises.
It's the hottest part of the earth.
So the hot air rises bringing up the moisture from the tropics.
As it rises,
it cools.
And what happens is hot air,
hot,
moist air cools rain.
So this is a very rainy region,
so now the air has risen,
it's dropped out,
it's moisture,
it's dry air.
The air that continues to rise pushes it away.
So it goes either north or go south and it now,
by the time it reaches somewhat farther away,
it's cooled a lot.
It's dry because it lost its rain.
Tonight you have cool dry air and because this region is sucking air back in,
there's a little bit of a vacuum.
The air falls back down as a cold from being up here,
cold,
dry air,
and you get the desert regions and they happened in the north and they happened
in the south.
So you get deserts here and you'll get desserts here.
This is just a characteristic of the whole world.
And of course this is interrupted by oceans,
this uninterrupted by something like the Himalayan mountains.
So there's a lot of,
uh,
not,
it's not a perfect a Schema,
but it explains an awful lot of the geography of the earth.
And in this Schema,
as I just showed you in Africa,
look how much of it is taken up with that Schema.
It's from here,
from the north edge of the Sahara desert,
for the south edge of the Kalahari desert.
It turns out it's 97% of Africa something now.
Yeah,
93% of African lion,
one of those three reasons,
very,
very wet jungle were too dry.
And you just have very thin region here in some region here,
which gets some of the monsoon,
a circulation of air,
of warm air out of the ocean.
Okay,
so we have the image of the wet tropics anyway,
as extremely lush and fertile.
And you'd think what a wonderful place,
uh,
for farming,
it's a tropical paradise.
Actually,
nothing is farther from the truth.
The tropics,
the tropics are generally very difficult to farm.
And if you do find them,
they're very poorly productive regions.
And why is this,
uh,
how many of you aware of that,
that the tropics are not good for farming?
All your forestry guys ought to be aware of this.
Uh,
the reason is that the soils are very bad.
So when they're bad for,
for a number,
uh,
of,
of of reasons,
um,
uh,
well let's go back a little bit.
So plant growth is very rarely limited by sunlight.
What the tropics have is plenty of sunlight,
but it's very rare that that is the limitation on,
on plant growth.
So the most productive part of the world is in terms of bio productivity is the
ocean around Antarctica.
Very,
very cold region in terms of intensity of some song.
Every part of the world gets the same number of hours of sunlight in a year.
But the intensity around Antarctica is very much less so.
It is very little sunlight.
Yet you get these tremendous algal blooms,
the krill eat them,
the whales eat the Krill,
and it's a tremendously productive region.
Why has nothing to do with sunlight,
has nothing to do with temperature?
Have Antartica the continent of Antarctica,
which has a rock down below it.
It's not like the North Pole.
There's rock there.
And the glaciers,
uh,
slide down to the scene.
They grind the rock.
So where the glacier is coming,
falling into the sea underneath is a layer of what they called glacier glacier
flower.
And that's ground rock falls into the sea,
fertilize the seed tremendously,
uh,
valuable.
They're tremendously nutrient rich.
And then that circulates up the west coast of Chile.
For instance,
the Pacific coast of Chile,
the Humboldt current you may have heard of,
brings up all these nutrients and the richest fishing banks in the world are off
Peru where the Humboldt current comes up and brings all these nutrients to the
surface.
So all over the world,
nutrients are almost always what limits agriculture?
Well,
what's the story in the tropics,
the soil may have started,
uh,
with a lot of nutrients.
It's sometime back.
Uh,
but,
uh,
the rains come huge amount of rain.
And what does rain do?
Washington nutrients back away.
So in most places,
nutrients are,
uh,
recovered by several mechanisms.
One is,
uh,
by,
mountains being eroded down that the,
that the mountains are road.
So just was in,
uh,
in February was in the Peruvian Amazon.
And you're sitting there right in the shadow of the Andes and the rains come
into the Andes,
the road,
the rock and parts of the Amazon have rich water flowing through it.
Uh,
with the Andes nutrients,
mostly Amazon is flat,
does not have any runoff from the Andes.
Mountains in fertile is hell no nutrients,
uh,
of there.
So how does the jungle,
you know,
so you have this nutrient poor soil.
If you go there,
you'll see the soil is extremely thin.
You take your boot,
you can kick it and uh,
uh,
a few and you know,
an inch or two and there's no,
no soil left.
And if you look at the trees,
what are the roots of tropical trees often look like these huge thing cause
there's not enough soil to support them,
you know,
on,
on deep roots.
There's nothing down there.
So they spread out and hopefully stay upright because with these huge,
huge buttressed,
uh,
kind of roots,
everything is telling you if you're not having to look at everything is telling
you that this is thin and poor soil.
But nevertheless,
there's all this biomass in the jungle and the mechanism is that the whole floor
of the jungle is covered with a fungus,
with a fungal mat and a leaf falls and just wet.
And so then it's never can,
cannot fall far from a fungus cause they were everywhere.
The Fungal Hyphae,
there's sort of a route of the fungus,
invades the leaf and very rapidly sucks,
sucks out its nutrients.
And then what does it do with those nutrients?
And one end of the fungus is attached to,
to the decaying leaves and other stuff that falls down.
The other end is attached to the trees and it gives these nutrients to the
trees.
Why is it so generous?
What are the cheese must be giving something to the fungus?
Well,
the trees are up there in the sunlight.
The jungle floors is dark.
Very,
you know,
there's canopy of the forest.
Let's very little sunlight really.
So they can't photosynthesize down the bottom.
Uh,
it's,
there's not a lot of grass and stuff,
uh,
under jungle trees.
So the trees make the sugars through photosynthesis,
they send them down,
pass them with the fungus,
the fungus dictates everything and sends the nutrients back up into the tree.
It's a wonderful cycle.
And so basically all the nutrients are up in the jungle canopy up in the,
up in the forest,
not,
uh,
in the soil.
Uh,
so this stuff,
this decaying,
uh,
vegetable matter,
um,
is the source of fertility.
And you measure how much of it there is and the productivity of the soil depends
very closely to the percent and depth of the humorous stuff is called Humus.
In the soil,
in tropical soils,
it's less than 2%.
Uh,
of,
of the soil that things live in is humus.
In temperate soils,
it's always over 10%.
In upper New York state or Ohio,
it's 10 to 12%.
And the richest Iowa farm lands,
it's up to 16%.
So you can see the productivity of Iowa is just going to be just from the soil
consideration is going to be an awful lot,
a greater than the productivity of the Amazon.
And another thing is the rapidity of decay aside anything that the fungus
doesn't get,
which is rare decays by bacteria,
uh,
and maybe other fungi that don't,
don't feed the trees.
And so it's hot,
it's hot all the time in the Amazon.
And what does temperature due to chemical reactions
speeds them up.
So for every 10 degrees warmer,
the chemical reaction in general goes twice as fast.
So in a jungle floor,
in a jungle,
you'll have maybe 30 degrees higher than New York state than Ohio or Iowa.
So that's two,
four,
eight decay.
We'll go eight times as fast as in say,
New Yorker in,
in my backyard to say nothing of the absence of the winter where decay basically
doesn't happen at all.
I know I make a mulch pile and it takes four years.
When I put in a leave,
four years later,
it's down to good soil and then it takes more years.
I don't know how many before that turns all back to carbon dioxide and water.
The whole thing is organic,
the whole thing.
Eventually it goes away.
Uh,
in a jungle it happens much,
much more quickly.
So to summarize all this,
this is,
you know,
you've got to have some biology,
this course.
Um,
so what is,
which is more fertile?
The Sahara desert or the Amazon basin,
the answer's really surprising.
And there is a quote annually,
millions of tons of dust from the Sahara or blown by the northeast Tradewinds
thousands of kilometers across the Atlantic Ocean there and they settle upon the
Amazon.
Some scientists suggest that this is one of the major sources of soil nutrients
for the poor,
poor soil of the Amazon.
So it's really not a,
not a mile situation.
It's very extreme.
If,
if nutrients from the Sahara can blow a few thousand miles and drop in and be a
very significant source of nutrients for the Amazon.
Okay.
Um,
now
what happens?
You try to farm this place,
try to farm in a jungle.
What do you do?
What you have to chop down the trees right now.
Mind you,
I told you that the forest floor is moist and dark and if any of you've been
there,
you'll know that it's very,
very striking.
It's you're not boiling all.
Now you cut down the trees,
the sun now beats down.
The tropical sun can be quite brutal and it dries out the soil.
It bakes the soil.
What dies?
The fungi die cause fungi need coolish and moist environment.
They die.
Your means of recycling nutrients is gone.
The soil has very little nutrients themselves.
What have you done with the trees that you're chopped down?
If you're a commercial agricultural place,
you shouldn't downriver to a saw mill.
Right?
So the nutrients that are there,
they're taken away.
The secret of what's called Sweden agricultural slash and burn agriculture is
that yes they do chop down the trees,
but in a very local,
very small plot of land and they burned the trees in place and that puts the ash
is the mineral nutrients which are so,
so missing in that fertilizes the soil.
It's not wonderfully efficient,
but it does work if you keep your plot small because then the fungus which is
killed there can re invade from,
uh,
the surrounding trees.
But you start doing commercial farming with many,
many acres of spread,
then there's no way that soil is going to regenerate.
Okay.
So how does this work out?
Uh,
so for instance,
in
the Yucatan of Mexico,
uh,
the Maya lived there for a very long time.
In the 16th century,
a Franciscan bishop,
Diego Delonda,
who is,
he wrote everything.
Everything we know about the pre precolonial a Mayan existence comes from him.
The UK tendency from him.
The Yucatan is the country with the least earth that I have seen since all of it
is one living rock and has wonderfully little earth.
And when you read all these chronicles,
they always are,
they're speaking oise of famines in the Yucatan cause there's so little,
uh,
productivity.
And how do they avoid the famines?
And this is again,
before the Spaniards calm,
uh,
they,
take care of their,
they have exports,
which they get food from,
from better regions.
And what are the export honey?
Which you don't have to farm soul,
which you don't farm and slaves.
That's another use for quote excess people and controlling your population.
You sell them as slaves and you look all over,
uh,
the,
the pre modern world.
And of course,
you know,
it's not going in the modern world.
Uh,
slavery is a very big thing in a very big part of what happens to population.
We'll talk a little bit about that later.
Well,
let me say it now.
Loans,
the topic came up.
What is slavery response to?
It's very relevant to the censure.
Under population.
You don't have enough laborers,
so you import
in the middle of Europe,
you know,
we have teaming populations or India or China or you can have an awful lot of
slavery.
No,
there's no land for them to,
to,
to be utilized.
Uh,
slaves get used like in the Roman empire,
not as farmers.
There were hordes of,
of,
of Romans peasants that would love to have some land to farm.
They're used in the mines.
There were household slaves,
sex slaves in the minds.
The Arab countries,
uh,
took a lot of slaves from Madec through Madagascar and continental Africa,
household slaves,
sex slaves,
somewhat in the minds,
but they didn't have that many minds.
So slavery is a response to under population.
Where do you get the huge slavery when you discover the new world and how you
have this very thin Indian population in these worlds?
Largely because we killed him with diseases as you,
you either have read or will read.
So we have an underpopulated to underpopulated huge continents.
We've much good land.
Uh,
you first in,
in,
in Western,
in history first you tried to enslave the Indians.
The Indians don't do very well.
They die out.
So you stop that and you import African slaves who managed to stay alive.
So slavery itself is a response to under population that fits exactly into what
I'm talking on.
A,
wherever you see massive slavery,
you're going to find under puppet going to find areas of land that have nobody
on them and someone can by military force capture people and forced him to work
for themselves.
Okay.
Um,
there's many other,
uh,
reasons why the tropics are hard to farm.
Uh,
where are the grain belts in the world?
What do you know about where grain grown?
Where's it really rich places?
Yeah.
Anybody.
US where in the u s Midwest.
Upper Midwest,
right?
Iowa,
Kansas,
Minnesota.
And does it go from north of the u s yeah.
Yeah.
Saskatchewan,
Alberta,
way the heck up there.
You have this fabulous production of grain and you see pictures of northern
Saskatchewan in Canada with a big grain reaper's,
right?
China,
where are the great grain fields of China?
Wheat.
I've been Manchuria right?
Goes up the north,
the northeast of China is all grain,
all wheat,
way up in dementia and men,
sure it goes up.
It's more or less the same as Alberta and Saskatchewan.
And in the south,
you don't get your great grain growing regions in,
in the tropical regions,
certainly not the desert regions.
You get them.
Uh,
Morocco for instance,
has very productive agriculture right on the coast where it's at wet region.
Uh,
that's not very far north and down.
South African,
African just doesn't go that far south in South America,
you get it down in Argentina.
So again,
so there's something that agricultural gets more productive the further north
you go with a limit.
Of course it doesn't go into the tropics.
And why should that be?
That goes contrary to our expectation.
And again,
the reason is biologically rather simple that during the daytime,
plants take in the sunlight and make sugar,
make energy,
right?
They also respired they also have to run them their own machinery.
So the also using energy,
using sugar all the time,
the user day,
and they use at night.
Right now the sun goes down and photosynthesis shuts down.
But,
uh,
respiration continues.
They have to keep themselves alive at night.
Just as we do.
We don't stop breathing when we go to sleep.
Um,
so the ratio between daylight and nighttime,
how much,
how many hours of daylight and how many nighttime is a very important factor in
plant productivity
in the tropics.
Uh,
what's the ratio of daylight to night time?
The whole year round about 12,
12 about equal.
What does it up in Saskatchewan or Manchuria daylight,
daylight,
daylight.
Very little nighttime.
So the plants have so many more hours in which they're photosynthesizing and
much smaller amount of time where they're not photosynthesizing but still
respiring.
So that's one big factor why you get these green belts going up north.
Also temperature.
So how much energy does it take you to just keep yourself alive?
Well,
we've just said all chemical reactions go every 10 degrees.
They more or less double.
So respiration plants,
the warmer they are,
the more respiration they have.
At nighttime,
it's still warm.
So every,
everything is working rather fast.
In the tropics,
in Canada,
man,
it's a lot of sun during the day,
but it cools off at night.
And so respray is a very low level.
So the productivity of a plant is the balance between its photosynthetic
production,
its production,
and its respiration.
It's use of that produce for its own purposes.
And there's a big difference in the ratio in the north from,
uh,
from Iowa to Saskatchewan or from,
the young seal up into Manchuria that that ratio is just much better than it is.
Uh,
in the,
okay,
so we won't continue too much with this.
We could also talk about the diseases that,
uh,
in tropical regions you get,
malaria,
you get a whole bunch of insect borne diseases.
Uh,
CDC flies,
carry sleeping,
sickness and et cetera.
One to 2 million Africans die of malaria every year.
And that's about the same number as aids.
It's malaria and aids are about equally devastating to a population.
Uh,
so it's about 11 to 22% of all deaths in Africa or are malaria deaths and yellow
fever,
lush,
Manassas bilharzia,
roundworm hookworm.
The number of parasites that live in tropical regions is enormous and very often
kill.
They kill humans and make them,
they can't go in there to farm because they'll get,
they'll die.
So why,
why are the tropics so much more susceptible to disease?
This kind of disease,
insect porn stuff then than the northern regions?
It's a simple factor.
Winter,
winter kills insects because the massively very hard for insects to not freeze
to death over the winter.
Tropics don't have winter,
so it's a whole class of problems.
They dry out,
the winter is extremely dry and they both desiccate and freeze and it's very
hard.
Organisms kill him in the tropics.
Nice.
All the time in six just have good time and they can evolve.
Is there evolution to attack animals and people?
Uh,
much better.
So all of this really adds up.
Angiography counts and people have to adapt to the geography.
In this case,
the adaptation is to an under population and I'm going to show you,
oh,
I'm going the wrong way.
Well yeah,
this is give you an idea of of how densely pop that Africa is or isn't here or
some European,
some non African places.
Netherlands is,
is one of the most crowded with in the world.
1,010 people per square mile.
Uh,
Japan,
870.
But that's in terms of arable land,
Japan is mostly mountains.
They just have very small areas where people can lend.
So to compare Netherlands offside,
people can live everywhere.
But you want to compare this to that.
They're probably per arable land worth more crowded than Netherlands.
Belgium,
same as on India,
China.
And again,
China's same thing.
They have the whole Himalaya mountains in the west,
the whole huge dry regions in the north to bed.
And uh,
I'm Mongolia and,
and the northwest regions.
So this is a way and underestimate,
uh,
for China.
Mexico has a lot of desert,
it looks fairly under populated,
but a lot of that is because you've got desert space.
Now you go to Africa,
Nigeria,
one of the most densely places is 346.
That's not,
not extremely since since Nigeria,
it's all not no mountains,
no deserts.
Uh,
in principle,
all of this land could be used.
So that's a real number.
Whereas the Chinese number,
you should multiply it by like a factor of three.
It's about a third of the Chinese land that's actually Arabelle.
So China's Ballpark of thousand in Nigeria is about a third of that.
Kenya is down.
And again,
Kenya is pretty much all livable and they have a little puncture pipe.
They didn't Madagascar's all livable and go is all livable.
Mali and Niger have deserts.
So those numbers have to be,
uh,
corrected.
Congo doesn't have have deserts.
So the point is that the at population density in Africa is a lot less than
other places that we think are,
are,
we don't think of Holland is over populated,
but in terms of of just a simple people per hour,
the land,
it definitely is.
And so Africans,
again,
we're looking at something that has a big historical component yet be careful
when I'm talking or what era of time I'm talking about.
These are modern numbers aren't going to show you.
Uh,
but they reflect people's attitudes that have changed,
are appropriate for some time in the past and only change very slowly.
So this is Morocco on the coast.
This is not part of the sub Saharan Africa zone.
This is very,
very integrated into the Mediterranean zone.
Almost everything you can say about its culture,
it's really a Mediterranean culture.
And look what's happened to its fertility over time.
It was very high,
more or less equal to every other place.
Seven,
I don't know how well you can see that 7.2 children per women and that stayed
the same.
But in recent times it's gone down to less than half of that 3.2 and this is not
the most recent data.
I wanted to show you a little bit older data.
It's going down even further in that zone of North Africa.
Tunisia is at a replacement fertility level and north Africa has characteristic
of this.
Now I'm going to show you the next country to the south,
which is Molly.
I'm s,
I'm sorry,
nine nine Ni.
Cheryl's as mentally he's also there.
But in Asia is when you go south,
you crossed the Sarah Desert and you're in sub Saharan Africa.
Now look at its fertility.
Say this even a little bit later in time.
And look at its fertility rate hasn't budged at all.
It's,
it's again,
eight,
seven,
eight children in the middle age children.
And it ends up here even more than it was in 1950s.
So it has not changed,
but the number of the fertility rate has not responded to whatever it is about
modern times.
And we'll talk about it a lot.
That has closed for charity to go down.
Now,
one thing you can say is,
um,
uh,
how many,
how many women don't want to have any more children.
And that of course depends on the number that you already have,
but it gets up to starts.
Women have no children,
very,
very few.
Most of them are children that they have one child.
That's enough for two at two children ready.
You have like 40% women race,
Santa Ana to children's enough for me.
Again,
this is Morocco,
uh,
in the Mediterranean zone.
And then when you get up to six children,
almost everybody says enough,
you know,
and the average of the whole country is,
that's like 53.3% more than half of the women,
uh,
say,
okay,
no more children.
And uh,
again,
this data is some years old.
It's even lower now.
And you compare this to Molly and this is the number of women that don't want
any more children.
I think the final layer is 8.6 or something.
An enormous difference.
And no matter how many children they have,
even this is eight.
And uh,
sorry,
six and more children still only very few.
About a third of them say,
okay,
six,
six or however many,
I have six and over is enough for me.
So,
uh,
let's see.
And this is,
uh,
in,
in respect of those two.
Um,
so you might say,
well,
uh,
Nisha is a very poor country of Morocco,
is not anywhere near support,
has something to do with like infant mortality.
And so this is indeed Morocco.
And look,
infant mortality has come down quite a bit.
It's,
it's,
it's getting there.
Uh,
and so you say,
oh,
well that's why Morocco Moroccans want,
want and have fewer children cause they have a better situation with infant
mortality.
But then you look at a new share and not,
it's not an,
it is not as good as Morocco,
but it's still come down quite a bit.
And since then it's come down further.
And you'd expect what you'd see some response in the fertility levels to that.
But you don't,
you don't see
it at all.
Uh,
what's the difference?
it's not religion,
so both knees share and,
uh,
Rocco is Sunni Muslim.
So,
and as far as I'm aware,
there's no big differences in the interpretation of,
of religion there.
And you see the same story in Christian sub Saharan Africa countries.
This is Tanzania again about the same years and basically no change in
fertility.
A little drop in very recent times.
A Zombie is coming up next Zombie,
it's even went higher and then it's down back to where,
approximately where it started.
So this is characteristics and not a religious thing.
It's there's something special about sub Saharan Africa,
even South America,
it doesn't look like this at all.
The fruit self Homeric the fertility's is way,
way down.
There is something quite special about Africa and we're going to have to try to
figure out what that is.
You'll read a really interesting article,
uh,
by uh,
John Caldwell,
um,
which talks about a whole culture of,
of reproduction.
And again,
Africa is a huge place,
has many different cultures and we're just talking to sub Saharan Africa was
north.
North Africa is a different story.
Uh,
South Africa where you have the,
the European settlement,
that's another different story.
But the bulk of,
of central Africa to some degree fits this.
You have places where you don't have bad soils.
So,
uh,
in the tropics,
Java has volcanoes,
volcanoes replenish the soil.
Uh,
the,
the mountain slopes of Kenya have have good soil from,
from again,
volcanic soil.
So the stories there are a little different,
but in general,
we're talking about those parts.
In Africa where it's hard to stay alive.
It's hard to get a population,
uh,
going that were the places traditionally underpopulated and adjust.
Now with Western medicine on the popular,
either population rates coming up to where you might consider it crowded and
places like Nigeria now is certainly a crowded.
Uh,
so
in Africa,
reproduction is at the core of the central core of traditional culture.
And their religious ideas are all tied in very centrally with reproduction and
the lineage itself,
that means your,
your line of ancestors and the prime duty of a human in this cultural setting is
to reproduce lineage,
keep the lineage going is not at all unique to Africa.
In,
uh,
in Indonesia.
I saw there's an awful lot of this going on in Sulawesi.
Oh,
I'll talk about other examples of it.
It's very,
it's very pronounced in Africa,
but non any sense?
Uh,
unique.
And the idea is that one of the ideas that when a man dies,
he doesn't just disappear.
We have a nice funeral service and say,
bye bye.
And maybe once a year we come in and give flowers,
uh,
onto the gray.
But we have no sense that that person is still around in these traditional parts
of the world.
Uh,
the person lives on in kind of a shadow,
a shadow world,
but he can communicate with his descendants.
That's not often not very difficult.
And he is dependent on his,
his descendants for sustenance.
Uh,
if they don't feed him and give him what he needs in the afterlife,
he is in big trouble.
And if a man does not have descendants,
then he really doesn't get anything and he dies.
And again,
I saw this in Bali enormously where there was an enormous effort to bring
offerings to,
to the,
the recently dead ancestors.
And they're very,
very sensitive about it.
You've seen Bali,
the women carrying these be on there.
They're beautiful.
And they're beautiful dress and they have these huge platters on their heads,
filled with the most delicious fruits and arranges just gorgeously.
And they bring him to the temple and the ancestors,
uh,
can partake of them.
And then the next day they come and take it home and eat it because they
understand that the ancestors are getting spiritual,
not,
not the physical stuff.
So they leave it there and then the ancestors can take what they get out of it
and then the humans can take what they get out of it.
So it's not wasteful.
And you see every store and every house will have a little everyday,
a little thing out in,
in,
in the front with a little bit of grain and everything.
And the dogs come buy and eat.
And of course,
the dogs come buy and eat it.
But that's okay.
The ancestors have taken in,
the spirits have taken what they want out of this.
So,
uh,
in temperate zones,
we associate religion and our culture,
big empires,
big states.
United States is huge.
And any Western country in populations is large compared to say,
a Balinese village or an African village.
And religion is big.
You know,
how many billions of Christians are there?
How many billions of Muslims are they're Buddhists,
Hindus,
you know,
we got every,
everything is is big.
Uh,
in Africa in a sense.
Each family's ancestors are it's gods and both political and traditional time.
Polk political authority and religion are very,
very local affairs.
They're not agglomerated into big things.
No one expects the people in this village to worship the same as the people,
uh,
in,
in the next village.
And so there isn't so much the idea of a central monotheistic type of God,
which is you use that comes up when you have empires.
We have a central emperor,
you have a central God,
but when you don't,
when you're a political thing is just your village.
Again,
traditional times,
uh,
there's no concept.
There's no need to have the,
these either central political leaders were central religious gods.
And so in mortality for you is provided by your descendants in mortality.
It's very local.
It's your own descendants that changes in,
in western London,
especially in the Muslim Judeo Christian tradition.
It's the religion.
It's God that gives you a mortality.
It's not your descendants.
So everybody's interested in mortality.
It's very important,
you know,
whether you go to heaven or Helen and so forth.
But the huge shift is whether it's given to you by your descendants,
whether they take care of you and give you a kind of immortality or it's given
to you by your big mega religion,
which tells you what you have to do in order to gain,
uh,
and mortality.
So when a person dies there again,
they don't go off to a distant heaven.
They stay right locally and gradually after a few generations,
they kind of disappear into the mist.
And they have a very careful departure.
So in again,
in Indonesia,
again,
comparing tropical region,
one of the big,
ours is called Sulawesi or celebes,
as we say,
in Western languages.
And in again,
many different cultures.
But in some of them,
a person dies.
You don't want to disturb that person because they can,
they can do bad stuff to you.
So you swat them,
he's going to rot.
So you've got problems so that you give them swaddling clothes and you sit them
in a chair,
him or her in a chair,
right in his own bedroom,
right where they live in houses,
sort of,
uh,
you know that houses and they sit there and,
and for a long time and gradually as they decay,
they smell,
they take off the swelling clothes,
get rid of that and swaddle them up again until they're down to bones.
And then they're taken up.
So they're not disturbed by that time.
Okay.
They're ready.
They don't have their flesh anymore.
They're ready to leave.
So the taking,
there's big cliffs overlooking the village and there's caves,
natural caves in the cliff and the dead bodies are brought up there to sit and
look down over the village.
They're not very far away.
It's,
it's really quite,
quite wonderful.
I was in Bali and stumbling around and funny circumstances in a,
in a cemetery and all these graves were open and I heard,
you know,
what's going on?
Are they expecting of the dug an awful lot of graves expecting everybody to die
soon?
No.
It turns out that uh,
a rich man had just died.
Now the poor people want to uh,
provide for their,
their ancestors in the next life,
but they don't have any money.
They don't have any stuff.
So they bury them and they wait until the rich man dies.
Then Richmond has this huge procession.
They're wonderful things to see with you know,
big caskets and big charities and all this just wonderful prepping and very rich
and the rich man body is thrown into the ocean and all kinds of stuff is thrown
into the ocean,
uh,
to support this,
this rich man in his afterlife.
Well,
the poor people and it's quite okay cause very communal culture.
Molly,
very supportive of poor people.
They dig up their bodies and they bring him in at the same time the rich man is
put into the ocean.
The poor people are putting into the ocean.
They partake of all of this.
And then what happens next day?
Of course,
the ocean,
all the coins and whatnot have come up up,
up on the beach and the rag pickers,
the really poor people combined collect all this stuff.
So it has the,
this,
this cultural act of,
of varying rich,
not only,
uh,
does equalize the afterlife for the rich people in the poor people,
but the very poorest people who are still alive get some income out of it as
well as,
of course,
everybody who prepares the funeral.
So it's a wonderful sort of way that everything sort of hangs together as they
usually do in cultures.
Okay.
Uh,
we will continue,
uh,
next time.